This finishes the lecture part of CS373, my basic introduction to robotic AI.
Even though we haven't done the final exam yet,
I want to congratulate you for getting this far.
The fact you got this far means you are really likely a very amazing student.
You put a lot of work into this--I know this.
It took me a lot of work to make those classes, but it probably took you even more to digest them.
I hope you learned a lot and had a lot of fun
and you feel empowered to program robots better than before.
What I taught you, I believe, is the very basic set of methods that any roboticist
should know about programming any robot intelligently.
All of those robots have tracking problems, state estimation problems,
planning problems, and control problems--be it a surgical robot, be it a robot maid,
or your intelligent future household robot ,
or even a flying robot, such as an autonomous plane.
I want to thank you for being with us so far.
The rest of this unit contains extra information on SLAM.
Otherwise, I'll just see you on the final.